Vsauce!
The Puss Moth Caterpillar is found in dense
woodland throughout Europe and Northern Africa
and is famous for having - a face.
It has a spike on the opposite end of its
face and can spray formic acid at predators
for self-defense.
Their cocoon is one of the hardest of all
moth species and the adult puss moth can have
a wingspan of almost 10cm.
What The Fak.
The Facts and Knowledge on Weird Bugs.
The giraffe necked weevil gets its name from
its enormously long neck.
Males necks are generally 2-3 times longer
than the females and they use it to fight
for the chance to mate with female weevils.
The females use their necks to create a nest
to lay a single egg.
And it's native to the warm climate of Madagascar.
The Devil's Flower Mantis is one of the largest
species of praying mantis.
It mimics flowers and its coloration is considered
an example of aggressive mimicry which is
a form of camouflage where a predator's patterns
and color lure prey.
They do this by climbing a plant and remaining
frozen near a suitable flower and wait to
capture their prey.
It's the only species classified under the
genus Idolomantis.
The Scorpionfly is not actually a flying scorpion
but an insect with a stinger that doesn't
actually sting.
It's the male genitalia of the scorpionfly
and females obviously lack this name-worthy
feature.
To court females the males often offer them
a meal and then the mating occurs while the
female is feeding on that nuptial meal.
Amazingly, males are also believed to sometimes
pose as females to steal these nuptial meals
from competitors.
The Golden Tortoise Beetle is native to the
Americas and notable for its shiny gold color
- giving it the nickname "gold bug".
The tiny metallic beetle was the first known
insect species that could rapidly change color
during copulation - or when disturbed by predators.
They have a transparent shell and then red
pigment that flows, reflects and can be drained
depending on the color it wishes to create
when stimulated or agitated.
The Stalk-Eyed Fly has long projections on
the side of its head that the eyes and antennae
are mounted on.
When they emerge from their pupae, the stalk
eyed fly gulps in air and forces it through
ducts and into the stalks, growing them as
large as possible.
The larger the eye stalks the greater potential
for reproduction because female stalk-eyed
flies prefer larger stalks and it gives them
a greater ability to fight off other males
for the females.
Camel Spiders aren't actually spiders they
are solpugids, but they do belong to the arachnid
family.
They became particularly notorious during
the Iraq War in 2003 when tales swirled about
them being blood thirsty and venomous.
And while they don't quite live up to legends
they are still pretty frightening.
They grow to 6 inches not including the legs
and can run 10 miles per hour.
Their jaws can be up to one third of the length
of their body.
And although they're not venomous they do
pack a powerful, painful bite.
Extatosoma Tiaratum are also known as the
giant prickly leaf insect, spiny leaf insect,
Macleays Spectre, or the australian walking
stick.
The females are much larger and covered with
thorny spikes for camouflage and protection.
They are so large that their wings by comparison
are too small for flight.
The males are smaller and only have spikes
on their heads, they also have the ability
to fly to avoid danger or find a mate.
If there are no males around the female can
reproduce asexually through parthenogenesis.
These eggs take twice as long to hatch and
produce only females.
I'm gonna leave you with this.
What is it and what will it become?
Before we go here's last video's winner.
I'd like to thank my good friends at the BBC
for providing much of the great footage in
this video.
Check out their channel Earth Unplugged and
this video in particular which answers the
question "What would the Fox really say?"
While you're there make sure you subscribe.
And as always - thanks for watching.